Palantir is known for helping
organisations harness data and AI
to make better decisions.
For defence, that might mean
optimising the availability of your
people, ships, planes and tanks,
or being able to rapidly identify
targets and what to hit them with.
We have worked with Western
militaries for almost 20 years.
That includes over a decade in the
UK, which is also home
to more than one in six of our
employees, the highest proportion
among the world's biggest 20 tech
companies.
And this is a thing that's perhaps
less well known about us.
Our software offers a foundation for
the brightest defence tech
companies, like Hadean,
to build on top of and deploy
their software at scale,
faster.
There are lots of challenges facing
disruptive technologies when
deploying into classified
environments, from long procurement
cycles and meeting stringent
security requirements to gaining
access to data and building a
software infrastructure that meets
the MOD standards.
This is why the MOD's commitment to
three month procurement cycles is so
important for defence startups in
the UK.
It's partnerships like the one
between Hadian and Palantir that
make rapid commercial exploitation
actually possible.
Hayden provides out-of-the-box
simulation and orchestration tools
that are used by armed forces to
rehearse, train, and plan
combat scenarios.
Leveraging the potential of AI,
these tools rapidly generate
scenarios that represent both
virtual and live environments,
greatly increasing the speed and
efficiency across the entire
mission planning lifecycle.
Hayden's Domini AI product is a
next generation command and control
system that accelerates planning
and decision making.
Through fully integrated AI and
simulation.
It embeds diverse data sources into
a single, clear, and actionable
format to provide real-time
situational awareness, allowing
users to simulate forward and
determine the best course of action.
Our AI needs to understand
military concepts the same way
operators do.
Units, missions, rules of
engagement.
Palantir is the bridge that lets our
simulation speak the same language
as our live operational systems.
Building this ourselves would take
years and delay capability delivery.
You need to integrate classified
intelligence feeds, logistics data,
sensor inputs, and historical
records, all with different security
classifications and formats.
Panantis solves this problem out of
the box, which means we can focus on
building the best products rather
than focusing on data plumbing.
This partnership with Palantir will
allow Haydn to turbocharge its
existing relationships with the MOD,
continuing to build on our
enterprise agreement and expand the
use of our suite of products.
Haydian is currently providing its
cutting edge training software to
the armed forces, but with
Palanter's foundry underpinning the
products, Haydians software can
integrate seamlessly with the
existing MOD data fabric and deploy
faster into live environments.
This partnership with Hadian is a
vital part of something broader for
Palantir in the UK.
We struck an agreement with the
Ministry of Defence earlier this
year to make the UK our European
headquarters for defence.
That agreement also formalised the
use of our software to help British
defence tech companies to bring
their technology into operational
use faster.
And also to help them sell into the
US, the world's largest defence
market.
The Ministry of defence has been
clear with us that this is what they
want us to do.
And we are determined to deliver.
It's an incredibly exciting mission
for us.
It will help to support our armed
forces, it will help keep our
country safe, and it will drive
the success of a new generation of
British defence tech companies.